ladies and gentlemen good afternoon I'm
Sid Gessler the administrator of the
Pulitzer Prizes welcome to the 97th
annual awarding of the prizes our
program is quite straightforward later
in the luncheon Paul Tash chairman of
the N CEO of the Tampa Bay Times in
florida and the new chair of the
Pulitzer Prize board will come to the
podium and address you briefly Paul is
someone who truly worked his way up a
native of Indiana and the top graduate
at Indiana University he started at the
times as a local news reporter and he
rose through the ranks to become its
editor and then chief executive the
Tampa Bay Times is Florida's largest
newspaper until 2012 the nice the
newspaper was known as the st.
Petersburg Times but it's changed its
name now that reflect the growth
throughout its growth throughout the
Tampa Bay region The Times is widely
respected as an American newspaper
through the years it is 19 pulitzer
prizes including one this year for
editorial-writing incidentally the board
has very strict rules on recusal if a
members own news organization is a
nominee for a prize the member must
recuse himself or herself and leave the
room during the discussion and voting
Paul is also chairman of the Poynter
Institute for Media Studies a school for
journalism and journalists and media
leaders that owns the times publishing
company in 2012 Paul received the
Distinguished Alumni service award from
his alma mater Indiana University and he
has recently been inducted
into the Indiana journalism Hall of Fame
Paul please rise be acknowledged
after paul shares his wit and wisdom he
will turn the proceedings over to Lee
Bollinger the president of Columbia
University and a member of the Pulitzer
Prize board who will present the 2013
prizes Lee is a distinguished First
Amendment scholar with what I like to
call good journalistic bloodlines his
father published a small paper in Oregon
and Lee has gone on to write and lecture
extensively on the importance of free
speech indeed as Columbia's president as
an author and as a Pulitzer Prize board
member he has displayed more personal
interest in the future of journalism and
free expression and probably any major
university president in the United
States Lee please rise and be recognized
ladies and gentlemen welcome my name is
Paul Tash and I'm the chairman of the
board of the Pulitzer Prizes and it is a
profound honor to represent my
colleagues on the board at the
celebration of extraordinary work in
arts letters and journalism let me start
by acknowledging the board's debt of
gratitude to our dedicated administrator
sig Gissler and his colleagues and his
colleagues on the Pulitzer staff it is
no mean feat to keep this machinery
humming the cycle that results today in
21 Pulitzer Prizes started with 2637
entries sig and his colleagues tended
that process as they do every year with
excellent judgment steady good cheer and
meticulous attention to detail the board
is also deeply grateful to our jurors
they are the 102 authors scholars
musicians and journalists who signed up
for Pulitzer Prize jury duty as many of
you know Pulitzer Prize winners have to
make it through two rounds of judging in
the first stage the jury's window the
entries down to just three finalists in
each category as the Pulitzer Prize
Board periodically reminds the world we
have the option by an extraordinary
majority to consider an entry that has
not been nominated as a finalist in a
given category even so we occasionally
give no prize at all for the first time
during my eight years on the Pulitzer
board
we found winners in all 21 categories
from among those finalists recommended
by our juries that result speaks not
only to the quality of our winners which
is superb but to the judgment of our
juries that is not to say that the
Board's decisions this year were quick
or easy they rarely are indeed the
quality of the discussion and debate is
what makes serving on the Pulitzer board
such a pleasure surpassed in my
experience only by my day job and by my
family when I was elected to the
Pulitzer board Tom Friedman welcomed me
to quote the world's best book club and
that description certainly fits but I
have also come to think of the board as
a wonderfully genial debating society
for two days each April we gather in the
journalism school around an oval table
in the room named for Joseph Pulitzers
newspaper the world without fail without
failed the discussions reveal a deep
reading of the finalists differences are
respectful and friendly but they are
also full throated settled ultimately by
a show of hands among board members no
score is kept and no scores are settled
any board member with a business or
personal connection to a finalist is
gently banished to the hallway for the
discussion and the vote you may not
always agree with the result although I
doubt there is much dissent from our
decisions represented in this room today
but in eight years on the board I have
never
sniffed even a whiff of doubt about the
integrity or the commitment of every
board member to recognize the very best
work our process is as intellectually
honest as humans can make it it is hard
to win a Pulitzer Prize this year like
every year I left New York struck by the
quality of many finalists who did not
win a Pulitzer Prize this year that
group included the winner of a National
Book Award a Harvard historian who has
won the Pulitzer twice before and a
collection of short stories that won the
richest international prize for such
writing in journalism the runners-up
included an expose that fire retardants
in furniture are mostly worthless and
toxic but that an industry campaign of
Lies bamboozled government officials
into requiring the chemicals anyway
other finalists in journalism one
triggered a review of 20,000 criminal
cases based on questionable forensic
science and got innocent people out of
prison to documented how a special
police agency was failing to protect the
residents of California's homes for the
profoundly disabled and three
demonstrated how supposedly nonprofit
hospitals in North Carolina are running
big surpluses while paying their
executive seven figure salaries and
skimping on charity care what makes this
year's crop of Pulitzer finalists even
more remarkable is the punishing
economic pressure on most of the news
organizations that have sponsored the
work my first Pulitzer board meeting was
in 2006 that was a high-water mark in
advertising revenues for American
newspapers since then the combination of
economic crisis and competition from
digital alternatives has sent
advertising revenues plummeting by more
than half today fifteen thousand fewer
journalists have jobs at american
newspapers than in 2006 people outside
our wonderful racket know that the
commercial enterprises that have created
most journalism are going through a
rough stretch and so they asked whether
the troubles have taken a toll on the
Pulitzer Prizes and the answer to their
usual surprised and a little to mine is
this not one bit the caliber of work
that gets to the Pulitzer board is as
strong as ever how to account for this
paradox I think journalistic ambition
burns both in organizations and
individuals despite the financial
challenges bankruptcy may no longer
carry particular stigma but it remains a
sign that an enterprise is under real
financial strain and by my count 11 of
the 42 finalists in this year's
journalism categories come from come
from journalists working at companies
that have sought the shelter of
bankruptcy protection so do four of the
14 Pulitzer winners you can feel the
strong pulse of journalistic spirit in
organizations big and small toward one
end of the scale journalists from the
New York Times one for Pulitzer this
year like The Times as other winners its
entry for international reporting was
hugely demanding and expensive beyond
the salaries and new
print it took to publish that work the
incalculable cost maybe in revenue lost
because the work imperils the company's
investments in China a huge and growing
market at the other end of the size
scale our prize for national reporting
goes to a start up with a full-time
staff of seven people and a history that
goes back six years in organization with
neither much resource nor history takes
the prize in a category that included
all the usual suspects and plenty of
heavyweights now we are about to turn to
the most important business of today the
presentation of the Pulitzer Prizes is
occasion not just for celebration but
also for inspiration that is a point I
will take from today's ceremony and
indeed from all my experience on the
Pulitzer board the work may be difficult
the odds may be long the challenges may
be great so what every day presents an
opportunity for excellence and the
chance to do work that makes a great
difference wherever we labor in
journalism let us make it a labor of
love thank you very much
and we turn now to our gracious host for
today a fellow member of the Pulitzer
Prize board the president of Columbia
University and a genuine gentleman and
scholar my friend Lee Bollinger